good afternoon everyone
i'm pleased to be here today with dr
hinshaw to provide an update on kovid
19.
dr insha will have more details in a
moment but i'd like to talk about some
broad trends that we are seeing
the data is for the period from tuesday
april 12 to monday april 18th
the trends are similar to last week the
data so far is mixed
there are increases in virus circulation
and hospital admissions but they're
smaller and moving more slowly than we
saw in the initial omicron wave
we are seeing some impact from the ba2
subvariant but so far it's much less
than we saw a few months ago with ba1
that's what we've been expecting based
on experience in other jurisdictions
such as bc and ontario and given our
high vaccination rate and recent
exposure to ba1
there are also some early signs that ba2
infections may be at a plateau
the average positivity rate of pcr tests
completed over the past seven days was
25.9 percent which is very similar to
the previous week's average of 26.6
percent
and wastewater levels are high in many
locations but they mostly remain below
the levels we've seen previously during
ba1
in edmonton the level is near the ba1
peak but in calgary it's rising more
slowly and in some locations the levels
are fluctuating or dropping and more
importantly we're not seeing the same
impact on hospital emissions that we've
seen before
hospitalizations due to covet 19 ticked
up this past week about three percent to
one thousand one hundred and twenty six
that follows a similar increase from the
week before
however we have fewer albertans in icu
due to code this week 43 compared to 46.
it's also important to look at the total
patient numbers in our hospitals because
covid is no longer driving excess
admissions above normal levels the way
it's done before
the total number of patients in our
hospitals has been stable for the past
couple of months
covet emissions have increased but the
total hasn't
the total is within normal bed base
overall and normal for this time of year
a couple of other key points
first there were 167 patients in our
adult general icu's this morning
compared to the normal pre-covered base
of 173 beds
the icu's have been within their normal
bed base on most days for several weeks
now they're still near at nearly 100
percent and that's too high
but it's a big change from the numbers
that we've seen before
and the system continues to complete
near normal volumes of surgery
the waiting list continues to come down
gradually it's currently about seven
thousand two hundred compared to seventy
six thousand six hundred at the
beginning of march and sixty eight
thousand before the pandemic
that's good but to be clear we're going
to bring it down a lot faster and i'll
be saying more about our plans to do
that in the coming days
as i said last week a few of the big
hospitals in edmonton and and in calgary
are over 100 capacity and that's a
concern obviously but it's also in line
with past years before covid and
likewise emergency departments and ems
are continuing to see very high volumes
of patients and that means delays and
long wait lists for some patients
i sympathize with patients and families
who are frustrated by these delays and
we're adding resources to try to keep up
but the reality is that the system is
stretched at times even in a normal
winter and there's a lot more pressure
on the system right now than in a normal
winter after two years of covet 19.
we need to recover from the pandemic and
we will but we need to do more
we're building more capacity into the
system so that it's not stretched so
severely
normal shouldn't mean stretching core
units way over a hundred percent a lot
of the time every year and in a bad year
canceling surgery even with covet 19.
for now covid remains a real threat but
we've come a long way
and we're going to keep moving forward
just three months ago we were living
with restrictions on social interactions
and capacity limits and public spaces
we're transitioning to living with covet
not by denying it but by relying on the
proven protection of vaccines
and also respecting people's freedom to
judge their own risk and take
appropriate precautions
there's no overstating the importance of
vaccination
we've gotten where we are today because
ninety percent of albertans have gotten
vaccinated and we need people to keep on
getting every dose of vaccine they're
eligible for
covid has not gone away the wastewater
data shows there's still a lot of it
around and if you're not vaccinated it
remains a real risk
we're getting through the current surge
without the kind of disruption we've
seen before
and some people may be thinking i'll
wait and get that third dose if things
get really bad again
please don't wait
there's enough omicron circulating right
now to be a real risk so if you're
eligible for another dose please get it
now
a reminder that fourth doses are also
available to all albertans aged 70 and
older
first nations inuit and metis people age
65 and older and all residents in
seniors congregate care facilities
provided that at least five months have
passed since your third dose
so please book an appointment for a
fourth dose if you or someone you care
about is in one of these groups
the alberta vaccine booking system is
always open and available online or you
can call 811 or go see a pharmacy close
to you
and reminder that we have covet 19
treatments available as well
paxlovid is a pill-based treatment that
can be taken at home but early detection
and treatment is key
it must be started within five days of
the onset of symptoms
with a positive covenant 19 test result
an assessment from a health care
professional
we currently have a supply of about
sixteen thousand courses of treatment on
hand with about ten thousand more
expected to arrive in the coming days
as of april eighteenth approximately one
thousand pack slovak prescriptions have
been dispensed up from about 720 last
week
all pharmacies in albertan can now
dispense paxolvid if they choose to do
so
we need to make sure that this treatment
is used in accordance with the evidence
and expert guidance and people who may
be eligible should call 811.
if you receive a prescription for pax
lovid please check the alberta blue
cross website to see which pharmacies in
your area are dispensing it and work
with your prescriber to have your
prescription sent there
the online list is updated on a regular
basis so please check for any updates
some pharmacies have had trouble
accessing enough supply early on but
we've now enabled them to place larger
orders with our central distributors to
meet the growing demand
for more information again please visit
the ahs website
we're still using a centralized system
for accessing pax love it that's similar
to most other provinces including bc and
ontario
we continue to monitor experience in
other jurisdictions the access process
was set up initially to manage a very
limited supply like other provinces
we've just recently had a big increase
so going forward
if we can plan on a consistently higher
supply then we may be looking at
increasing access as well as making
changes to make the process easier
now we've come a long way and we're
going to keep moving forward thanks to
the hard work of our healthcare
professionals and the willingness of
millions of albertans to roll up their
sleeves and get vaccinated so thanks
again to all of our healthcare
professionals continuing to work day in
and day out and have done for the last
two years and are doing sue doing right
now
particularly in edmonton and calgary
managing higher volumes and with that
i'll now doctor invite dr hinshaw to the
podium
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
as the minister mentioned the numbers
we're sharing are from the reporting
period tuesday april 12th to monday
april 18th
in the seven days our pcr test
positivity ranged from 20.8 percent to
30.2 percent
as the minister mentioned there are
currently 1120
people with covet 19 in hospital
including 43 in the icu
sadly between april 12th and april 18th
an average of seven deaths per day
related to coveted 19 were reported to
alberta health
these losses and others that have
happened due to any cause
leave holes in our families friend
circles and communities
and my sympathies are with anyone who
has lost a loved one
as transmission continues with ba2 we
have seen more breakthrough infections
in those with a full vaccine series
given that i know there are questions
about the importance of vaccines right
now and i want to remind albertans of
what the data shows us
when we look at the difference in the
risk of severe outcomes by vaccination
status
it is very clear that vaccines are
critically important in lowering the
risk for hospitalizations and deaths
if we look at everyone in alberta age
five and up in the last four months
those who were not vaccinated were more
than three times more likely to be
hospitalized with covid19 and almost
eight times more likely to be admitted
to icu than those who had three doses of
vaccine
for those aged 80 and older in whom the
risk of severe outcomes is highest
those who were not vaccinated were more
than four times more likely to be
hospitalized with covet in the last four
months
and almost six times more likely to die
from covid than those who had three
doses of vaccine
it has always been true that most people
who get covered do not need hospital
care
and especially with high two-dose
coverage at this point the initial
infection will be mild for most people
some individuals may not even notice
their symptoms until a couple of days
have passed owing to spring and allergy
season
many may be tempted to shrug off these
mild symptoms and continue to go about
their daily business
to work to run errands to take part in
regular activities
however it's important to remember that
doing this can have serious consequences
for others around you
the rules for isolation in our province
remain the same
if you test positive or have symptoms of
covid19 you are required to isolate at
home and away from others
for those who have two or more doses of
vaccine this is for a minimum of five
days or until symptoms resolve whichever
is longer
for those with one or no doses of
vaccine the requirement is for 10 days
or until symptoms resolve
if you feel sick even if you test
negative please stay home and away from
others until you are feeling better
this means not going to work school or
any other activities outside the home
in addition to staying home when sick
it's also important to remember that
there are still precautions in place in
settings where those with high risk
factors are present
masking is required in continuing care
and acute care as well as on public
transit
if you visit your doctor's office or
another health care service be prepared
to wear a mask to protect those around
you
and make health care settings safe
spaces for everyone
this transition period is allowing space
for all of us to adjust
both back to a somewhat more normal life
and also adapting to the new
considerations that each one of us must
take into account
each person's balance of risks and
benefits is different and the many
decisions each of us have to make every
day are also informed by what the
transmission risk is in our communities
it can be helpful to check the weekly
data updates looking at waste water
trends and geographic distribution of
cases to get information on what your
local exposure risk is like
you can also consider how many people
you will be around and what their
exposure risks might be as a guide to
the kinds of precautions you might take
such as masking or distancing
it's also important to remember that all
of us face many risks every day
and covid is one risk among these many
we have focused on it primarily for a
long time and yet now our context is
different
it's important to remember this also as
we try to balance the competing
considerations in our lives
please be patient with others and with
yourself as we all navigate through this
time and continue to do what we can to
keep all of us safe and healthy thank
you and we're happy to take questions
thanks dr insha and minister copping um
no one here in the room with us so we'll
go to the phone and i think we'll have
time for three callers so we'll take the
first right now please
this question is for the health minister
um
for the basically the last month
we've noticed reports online of alberta
doctors mostly er doctors kind of taking
turns painting ugly pictures of
emergency rooms in the province i know
you've acknowledged the situation
yourself at that podium last week there
was a code orange situation
at the university of alberta hospital
one patient waiting upwards of 20 hours
ahs says the current situation is being
made worse by a significant number of
high acuity patients including covid
patients
and then another local doctor reported
about a rough night at
rah last night so i'm just wondering why
do you think the current situation in
ers is worse than usual
well part well thanks for the question
and i have we've spoken with a number of
doctors as well
we have certain areas of the province
and in certain hospitals so like the u
of a
we have higher than normal 100 percent
over 100 capacity in terms of uh
in terms of the emergency rooms uh so
we're conscious of that we know that as
overall the system uh we're not at that
level so it depends on the on the on the
location you know some of that's being
driven by uh by covid uh and some of us
driven by the the care deficit um that
we've had you know so so we've had
individuals who have um over the course
of covid not seen their family
physicians uh as frequently as they they
may have normally would given concerns
with covet uh therefore the acuity of
the illness that
that they're they're facing uh has gone
up and then now they're coming into the
emergency departments so one of the
things that we are doing with with our
budget is working to expand capacity uh
within our hospital systems overall uh
in terms of
we've done that with the with the icu
100 million dollars in specific that and
we've also asked that you know if we
don't need that those those dollars for
the ic
icu to be able to use the resources uh
elsewhere and build capacity within the
system so we're recognizing that this is
an issue
we'll work through that as we we learned
we learned to live with covid and
through uh what the the current uh ba2
wave uh and then continue to build
capacity so that you know we can quite
frankly normalize um and and not saying
it's ever going to be normal but we
shouldn't have to be over a hundred
percent on regular times a year and and
and the only other concept that i would
provide is that you know we're dealing
with covert right now but but also we
you know flu seasons uh we've had to
deal with this in in the past not not as
uh severe
and not the high not as high as levels
but we need to actually invest into our
health care system which we're doing so
that you know we don't have people doing
a high dive to provide services all the
time but this takes time so we have
budgeted for this year and then the next
the next few years to be able to do that
as we recruit and train more staff
thanks minister dan do you have a
follow-up
yes sorry how much
do you feel you know community supports
outside the hospital
should be part of that
expansion that you're that you're
talking about
so when we talk about expansion it's
it's not only within the hospitals per
se so it's not only acute care um it is
also you know we've had additional
funding has been allocated to ems but
also we've additional funding you know
into
home care community care
and and continuing care because as you
know
there is a a pipeline for some
individuals who are going to acute care
and then move into
moving to continuing care and we need to
be able to have the spaces available so
we're investing in all aspects of our
health care system so you know that
plays in a very very important part as
as does
their primary care you know to the
extent that we can we can increase our
ability to provide primary care um then
we can address the acuity issues and we
have that the percentage of the people
who are who are more acute you know have
higher levels of acuity and then now
present themselves to the emergency
department will go down but that's going
to take some time and quite frankly
we're going to have to work through the
backlog that kovat has is presented for
us
thanks minister i will move to the next
caller please
allison mckinnon ctv
hi there when talking about uh third
doses alberta is actually ranked last in
all of canada at 46
wondering if the province has any plans
to kind of do a big push to get people
that third notes like they did when we
were talking about getting ready for the
stampede
so the short answer is yes we are
working on a on a campaign to increase
our third doses
you know one of the things and and we
and dr hinchell might be able to comment
on this uh
uh more but one of the issues that we're
also dealing with is that uh lots
there's a large proportion of the
population who uh who got ba1 um
and uh and then you know the advice from
uh the national advisory committee is
that you you know sort of wait 90 days
until then you get you another shot well
we're almost at that point now um so
you'll you'll be seeing in the coming
weeks a campaign to ask people to get
their shots and that
their their third dose because it's
going to be important to protect against
severe outcomes um i made my comments
today and i know doctor hinch also made
her comments today in terms of doing
that and you'll see a broader campaign
coming in a couple of weeks and dr
hinshaw if you want to comment any
further on that
i would just again emphasize the
importance of that third dose as well as
the impact you know certainly there's
been some work done with focus groups to
understand what people are thinking
about their doses and that's something
that we've certainly heard is people who
did have an infection in the fifth wave
who are waiting for that three month
time period so
that's one factor and again just would
emphasize how much
of a difference that third dose makes
and how important it is for anyone who's
18 or older to access the protection
that that that third dose provides
thanks dr hinshaw
follow-up
alison yes um with having to wait those
three months or 90 days
is there a risk of these shots expiring
and when will we see all albertans
eligible for that force so
my understanding of the expiry dates is
that the product we have is not
due to expire in the in the short term
that's something that we could certainly
follow up on and and
get that information but i don't believe
that that's a risk in the near term
with respect to the fourth dose it's
important to remember that vaccines just
like antibiotics or any other
therapy that's used are important to use
in the
right population at the right time to
get the maximum benefit and so we are
working with
the national advisory committee on
immunization and our own alberta
advisory committee to understand what
populations benefit the most from
additional doses and at this point in
time again the the protection from
severe outcomes that three doses offers
is important for those who are 18 to 69
those who are 70 and up that fourth dose
provides a benefit
but it's really important that we are
using vaccines again like any other
medication in the way that that provides
the most benefit to the people who
receive them and so the question of of
when um additional populations may be
eligible
again that's something that we're
constantly looking at the evidence and
reviewing what is coming forward
and that recommendations are made based
on best available evidence at that time
thanks dr hanshaw
we were hoping to wrap up by four so
we'll take one last call please
emily merch global news
thanks for taking my question this is
for dr hinshaw i'm just wondering what
alberta is seeing in terms of
reinfection or breakthrough infections
how often are people
catching the virus a second or third
time and is it usually with a different
variant
we
don't have of course specific
information because we know that many
people at this point in time are testing
with rapid tests so we wouldn't know
about those individuals in the data that
we're collecting so the pcr testing that
we're doing right now is really focused
on those who are individually at high
risk or those who work in high risk
settings so we would only be capturing a
subset of those who might be having
additional infections
the
the data that we have does indicate that
there have been
reinfections certainly we we saw with
the initial omicron wave in late
december and january that there was more
breakthrough infection with that i don't
have current data with respect to
breakthrough with respect to those who
may have had a ba1 and now have ba2
but we do know that other jurisdictions
have reported breakthrough infections
even in people who again had infection
within the
previous several months so we know it's
possible the bottom line is that there's
also influenza circulating as well as
kovid
there's multiple respiratory viruses and
so it's really important if someone is
feeling sick that they stay home and
away from others because whether it's
covet or whether it's influenza or
something else even if the individual
who's feeling ill may not have risk
factors they could pass it on to someone
for whom it could be very serious so
again that's why i want to emphasize the
importance of staying home when sick no
matter what the cause is
thanks dr henshaw emily follow-up
yeah i'm just wondering since so much of
this information is
sort of offline because people are doing
the rapid testing
is there anything in the works or was
there anything discussed about asking
people to log their rapid test results
or their experiences with long covet for
instance on a website or something like
that just so alberta could have an
understanding
when we move from pcr to rapid tests
like other jurisdictions have done
when we did a scan across the country it
seemed that
most of the
colleague provinces who had a reporting
system weren't using that as a part of
their their overall data system
so typically it was a way for somebody
to to track their tests we do have a
form available on our website people can
use to
download and document a positive rapid
test result for their own personal uh
needs that they can choose to disclose
to others again for their for their own
immediate health needs so that is
available on our website and
again
there would be multiple challenges with
using rapid test results as part of the
data stream so that isn't something
we're looking at at this time again
consistent with other provinces with
respect to long coverage there is a
survey underway that
my understanding is that alberta health
services has been working on this to try
to understand the prevalence of lancovid
the experience of people who have that
and of course that is something that we
need to continue to work on documenting
so someone who may not have had a pcr
test can still of course have an
experience with long covid
and they
will be able to access the care that
they need for those symptoms whether or
not a pcr test was done at the very
beginning of the of the illness so again
that that la that pcr test presence or
absence will not stop someone from
getting the treatment that they need for
whatever symptoms they may be
experiencing
thanks dr hanshaw and minister so we'll
wrap there and see you here again next
week thanks very much